Center let's bring in South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham Senator thank you
very much for joining us ahead of this
White House Press briefing we'll see
what happens there obviously we know my
orcas will be will be present I just
want to put up this map so our viewers
can see you just heard what's happening
in New York Chicago these uh non-border
cities that are dealing with this
migrant crisis the this is El Paso Yuma
Tucson San Diego Del Rio they are
dealing with this this influx of
migrants that they can no longer handle
we're hours away now from the lifting of
title 40 42 what is your prediction will
happen
uh that you'll have a press conference
that will talk about changes that really
uh won't matter they're incapable in my
view the body administration of changing
policy to stop the flow because they're
held captive by the left this is not
chaos this is catastrophic we're
literally Under Siege when it comes to
Legal immigration the amount of drugs
flowing in this country is an all-time
high how hard would it be for somebody
to get into this crowd of people that's
a terrorist to kill a bunch of us so
this is catastrophic uh the people in
charge of securing our border should be
fired and if you want to change policy
you got to get a new President Joe Biden
will never change policy to bring the
Border back under control because he
can't do it I mean even if you've got a
new president Senator it would be a
couple of years before that person was
sworn in so that a lot of damage can be
done by absolutely influx of illegal
migration uh we got the two minute
warning for the briefing so we'll keep
an eye on that uh meantime senator
thought this was interesting Joe Biden
using the word chaos yesterday to
describe the situation in the Border
listen here
look the perfect what we're doing now is
making real immigration more streamlined
[Music]
immigration shorter term than move and
through the direction that people know
that there's a legal way to get here and
I'm not a legal way yeah they're
promoting the legal way to get here
Senator not the illegal way though they
continue to let people in on mass as
we've seen every day he didn't say it
was a crisis this idea of acknowledging
that it's chaos well I try to be
respectful to the president I've
actually known President Biden for a
long time and he's a decent man but what
he just said is BS
it hasn't been a couple of years of
chaos it's been Chaos on his watch
December of 2020 we had the lowest
illegal Crossings in the last 40 years
President Biden can you not figure out
what happened you repealed all of the
Trump policies that worked and replaced
them with open border policies and
you're surprised we have chaos I don't
think he's capable of making these
changes politically I think he's out of
touch with what it takes to to secure
our border I don't think he has the
political will to secure our border and
it's just a matter of time to America
suffers moddedly the human tragedy is
just just hard to put your head around
fentanyl is an all-time high and I'm
telling you right now between the
withdrawal in Afghanistan and this chaos
and catastrophic uh Invasion on the
border it's just a matter of time but
somebody gets in this country and kill a
bunch of us unless body changes policy
you know Senator I just want to speak
specifically to the live images that our
viewers are seeing on the screen there
are Drone footage Brownsville Texas a
moment ago you saw those those piles of
clothing and garbage and materials that
are left behind by these migrants making
this journey you know the president
acknowledged chaos but is it chaos is
anybody shocked by this or is it a well
executed strategy Senator it is a choice
this is not an accident they chose the
Biden Administration to repeal remain in
Mexico which stopped illegal immigration
Asylum Seekers they chose to do away
with the agreement Trump had with the
northern triangle countries you had to
apply for asylum in the country not at
our border they made a choice to change
all those policies they've done nothing
to secure our border after they made
these choices and here's what I think
there's elements in the bite
Administration that want more illegal
immigration not less they've granted
parole to 60 000 people in the entire
Trump Administration 10 people got
parole regarding illegal immigration
they're making a conscious effort to
allow as many people in this country as
they can get in I think so after title
42 comes off Senator we go back to title
eight which has been around since 1968
to take care of illegal immigration uh
here's just a quick analysis of what the
difference is expulsions under title 42
versus title eight under title 42 one
age income process and send as many as
40 migrants back to Mexico in some five
minutes without title 42 back with title
eight it'll take one agent 30 minutes to
an hour to process just one migrant and
determine where he or she will go next
with 10 000 migrants coming across our
border every day and that number
expected to increase when title 42 comes
off what's going to happen to the system
well you see it on your television when
Mallorca speaks and he says our borders
secure he's lying okay they must not
have a television uh in his office
or maybe they just don't subscribe to
Fox
because if you watch Fox News the rest
of the day you will see chaos and
catastrophic results in our border
they're doing nothing substantially to
correct it so there comes a point where
you have to believe they mean for this
to happen now when Trump says the
election was stolen and I don't believe
it was every news Outlet in the country
fact Checks In when my orcas in the
Biden Administration tell you that the
border is secure not one person outside
of Fox News and conservative media
pushes back why do they keep saying this
because they get away with it well we
just show the pictures you don't need to
be this is not rocket science you see in
real time the consequences these policy
changes there's human tragedy with this
garbage only God knows how many women
have been raped children have been
sexually exploited how easy is it to get
fentanyl in the middle of this crowd but
I'll say it again and I'm going to keep
saying it to something changes how easy
would it be under these policy changes
for a terrorists to penetrate the
southern border and kill a bunch of
Americans to have another 911. they have
paved the way for that by two things
withdrawing from Afghanistan in a
reckless Manner and having an open
border we're on borrowed time and that's
not a matter of time that's not even a a
crazy out there thought Senator because
we just learned this week that there are
plans under this Administration now to
release migrants into the United States
with absolute absolutely no tracking of
them I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis